and Russia this morning there are
questions over the two generals
commanding Russian forces in Ukraine who
have not been seen in public since last
weekend's Rebellion President Vladimir
Putin has been making public appearances
reasserting control after the Wagner
group's private Army briefly threatened
Moscow on Saturday Ian Lee talked with
the Ukrainian president's National
Security adviser in his first interview
since the uprising
adoring supporters greeted President
Vladimir Putin in southern Russia
yesterday the Kremlin projecting a
leader who's popular and in control
but questions remain surrounding the
mercenary boss yevgeni pregosians failed
Insurrection last weekend CBS News has
learned the U.S has Intelligence that a
senior Russian general had Advanced
knowledge of the Mutiny raising the
possibility that the Wagner leader
believed he had support from within the
Russian military the Kremlin said
yesterday these allegations are
speculation and gossip but in Kiev
Ukraine's National Security chief o Lexi
danoloff claimed pagosian was in League
with not one but 14 senior Russian
Military Officers pagosian does have
support in the highest ranks of the
Russian military
is not an independent person he is owned
by high-ranking people in President
Putin's Inner Circle
one senior General widely reported to be
involved is Sergey sort of vegan who
hasn't been seen since telling mutineers
to return to base was he one of the
generals that took part in this Mutiny
which there should be do you want me to
name them all
yes
I can't
many analysts say President Putin has
been weakened by this revolt and Daniel
off believes he may face another
attempted Uprising
even if he executes the generals who had
some sort of part in the Mutiny this
will not affect the outcome the wheels
are in motion for Putin's demise
danoloff also believes the failed Mutiny
and Chaos in Russia will eventually
benefit Ukraine in the war against
Russia for CBS morning's Ian Lee in Kiev
Ukraine